uh
gps yeah so there are some
um
there's some options to control that um
you but not the to the level
and is it 2d and 3d
okay all right
but so 3d we have
you know there's like been work done for
example at the summer school on this
question of given an object given the 3d
geometry what are interesting points
with respect to that geometry
do you understand what i'm saying
yes roger you understand what i'm saying
right yes
interesting views i think you talked
about yes
okay so but
i mean
what do we think conceptually you've got
a 2d image
presumably there are salient points in
that image that you need to hit right
we're presumably looking at that with
image processing yes or no
we can that sounds reasonable
this version of the function doesn't
have it
what are we doing right now what is the
canonical thing to do given that you
have a 2d image right and you're going
to
you know be wandering around it what is
the thing that you think you're going to
do
the the karen implementation proposal
doesn't have any automatic selection of
points or zoom levels
the user has to explicitly ask i want to
zoom in i want to pan from left to right
or whatever
okay how does this relate to the design
of the
all this geopath design and things like
this
other path designs
you know position time paths
it hasn't been connected to that yet no
i haven't looked into that
okay in fact the design review that i am
already late for as a flight data maybe
you guys maybe what we maybe you guys
should join that
meeting because that is precisely
talking about this issue
um
i think i need to go to that but but why
don't you join it from that because
talking about exactly this this is a bit
late for me so i might have to skip
i can join i'm in italy at the moment oh
okay as opposed to california well fine
colorado now
oh okay
okay
i'm glad i'm coming back
um
uh okay
um
when will video work in cloud
it does now all this stuff and actually
we don't have issues with the gui there
because we just use whatever the browser
provides us with yeah but can you can
you get
the video to compute yes yeah
cool
okay in any case look what what you're
describing here okay so those who can
please please join this flight data
thing um
uh somebody send out the information
about that
um okay
and uh
all right we're gonna need another
how long roger
well i think i think at the rate we're
going i'm guessing
kind of two more hours actually i think
so too
how difficult are some of these other
things yeah well this stuff down here is
not the import export is not difficult
and
the image stuff the smaller updates
again are easy they are easy yeah
i think the stitching is going to take a
little bit of time to a video is going
to take a while
that one is uh
yeah
because we're designing something it's a
new idea
right so this stuff looks looks like it
could be done in an hour
yeah but that that's what i mean if
you're gonna get through this whole
notebook i think we have why don't we
why don't we break off the graphics tour
video
discussion and then get through the rest
of this
plan an hour for the rest of this
we'll we'll put graphics to a video at
the end of that if we can if we still
have time
for a separate meeting
okay not a problem
okay so why don't those who uh can join
us in the next meeting about flight data
that will also be live streamed well
we've had a real live stream
festival today
um
and uh
uh yeah wow this is really uh i'm
looking at my calendar this is this is
both a design review and live streaming
season
okay
all right see you guys in a minute